Hey everyone Diavolo here and In todays video
we are going over One of my favorite fights from
throughout the dope ass series that is Tatsuki
Fujimotos Chainsaw Man. So like this may not
be the flashiest or the craziest fight in the
series, but personally I think this fight here,
The Chainsaw man vs Katana Man battle which pits
our reps at the bureau against some dirty ass Gun
Devil agents is one of the greatest fights in the
entire series! ESPECIALLY the first half of it,
as it symbolizes the moment pretty much
everything changes inside of this world.
Like our perception gets utterly flipped on
its head as we realize the TRUE brutality
that the series has in store and not just
that, ITs the moment I think you start to
see just how good Tatsuki Fujimotos writing
actually is as everything that he’s been
building up with Denji and the story so
far starts falling perfectly into place!
Also yeah I got hit with the big 3
as you can probably hear yourself,
first it was the pup who we had to rush to the
vets as she was having seizures BUT luckily
she has turned out perfectly fine after 2 nights
there. Then I had to have my freaking wisdom teeth
start coming through literally messing up my jaw
AND THEN get horrendously sick at the same time,
which just ruined my upload schedule as I
was stuck in bed for 2 odd weeks.. However
im starting to feel slightly better now! SO
SUBSCRIBE WE ONLY LIKE 1k OFF 100k SO THATS
ACTUALLY MENTAL Cant thank you all enough for
the support recently its been freaking crazy,
buuut anyway enough of me creaming
over how well the channels doing,
time to jump into this Ramen store
just before everything kicks off!
Inside a random ramen shop while the main core of
Division four chills out they hears the a bunch of
gunshots in the distance, but they just assume
they're merely drum beats. A stranger on the
table next to them then speaks up insulting
the quality of the ramen. Denji and Power
are both offended by this and the man sitting
there comments on the peers unrefined palette,
remarking that those who do not eat much
in their youth gain a poor sense of taste
later in life… Sensing that something
wrong Aki tells them all to leave,
but the random man continues talking. He
begins discussing his beloved grandfather
whom would often spoil him.. Then in a moment that
probably makes Denji start tripping reveals his
grandfather to be the old man who raised Denji
and was later possessed by the zombie devil…
He accuses Denji of causing the old man's death
(Which like ngl bro, man kinda messed up your
grandad. Pretty sure he’s lying somewhere like the
inside of that shed, cut into a bunch of different
pieces..) Anywaysss he then states that the gun
devil wants his heart, he then quickly whips out a
gun and shoots Denji directly in the head killing
him, before shooting Himeno in the chest and Aki
in the arm.. Before he can continue though, best
girl power punches him knocking the gun out of his
hand. Aki then instantly summons the fox devil
to devour the mysterious dude. Looking over he
worriedly see’s Denji’s dead and unmoving body as
well as Himeno’s critically injured state. Taking
Aki by surprise, the fox devil then suddenly
informs him that the man was neither human
nor devil, before its head is viciously torn
apart from the inside and the man re-emerges,
revealing himself to be a devil-human hybrid
fused with the one and only katana devil…
Aki orders Power to stop Himeno’s bleeding then
pulls out his infamous sword and unleashes it
for the first time. Looking at it Power is
surprised to see that it resembles a nail
rather than a blade, Katana Man initiates the
battle by swinging at him, but Aki dodges before
readying in his blade and shouting fire. Eerily
a devil slightly appears and is shown flicking
the nails point into the Katana Mans body
as a disembodied mouth is then seen sounding
the number three.. Confused with what happened,
the Katana Man hesitates before swinging again,
Aki once again dodges shouting fire once more
and piercing the devil human hybrid once more,
again the disembodied voice speaks saying
the number two. Finally Aki makes a lunge,
piercing the Katana Man's belly
with the curses voice stating one..
The Katana Man knocks him back showing confusion
over his plan, however Aki calls out to the devil
telling it to finish him.. As the devil appears
it states zero! causing a massive disembodied hand
to grow and grab the Katana Man. Momentarily he
expresses shock before LITERALLY being torn limb
from limb by the giant skeletal devil, then
being left to fall to the floor unconscious
and bleeding profusely.. Aki calls out to
Power who recommends getting Himeno a doctor,
leaving him shocked by the use of a gun and the
man's ominous statement regarding the gun devil..
Suddenly a young woman appears
commenting on the cursed devil's power,
seeing her Aki asks whether she’s working
with the katana man or not. Stepping
forward the girl doesn't even respond
and simply picks back up the hybrid,
she asks the Katana Man why he lost so easily to
which he ashamedly responds that he let down his
guard. Reinitiating the battle he orders him to
kill the group quickly, leading the Katana Man
to lunge forward at Aki and before our boy can
even respond his chest is suddenly slashed by
the katanas protruding from him. Aki heavily
injured from the attack drops to the floor,
Sawatari, whos the chick btw completely forgot to
introduce her buttt yeah anyways she comments on
how the wounds are likely non-fatal due to
the bureau’s suits being reinforced with a
special material. Himeno tells Power to forget
about her and instead help Aki however Power
just refuses as she's utterly terrorfied
and believes herself to be far outmatched.
Himeno attempts to summon the ghost devil but
it refuses out of pure fear of Sawatari and
her curse, as a last resort in an attempt
to save Aki, Himeno offers her everything
to the ghost devil. Instantly the devil's
grimace turns to a smile as its true giant
form is finally revealed. The ghost devil then
starts to attack against the Katana Man and with
each attack Himeno loses more and more of
her body sacrificing it all to her devil,
as this happens this she thinks about
her love and remarks on how unusual it
is that he was still able to cry as most devil
hunters grow emotionally stunted over time..
As Aki looks at her she tells him not to
die as she wants someone to be able to cry
over her death.. (Damn so I aint come through
with the holy cut offs this video, BUT this
is the exact moment in the series where I TRULY
REALIZED JUST HOW MESSED UP TATSUKI FUJIMOTO IS,
DUDE IS JUST LIKE GEGE IN THE REGARD THAT HE DOES
NOT CARE AT ALL ABOUT YOUR DAMN EMOTIONS AT ALL,
HE’s A DEMON WHO’s LEGIT JUST TRYNA DESTROY
THEM. LIKE THE SERIES TAKES SUCH A DRASTIC
TURN AT THIS EXACT SPECIFIC POINT ANYWAYS.
As Sawatari summons her snake pause devil
ordering it to devour Himeno’s Devil it. It
does so, launching a bunch of attacks and
leaving nothing at all of Himeno aside
from the clothes laying on the floor.
Sawatari and the katana man turn to Denji’s
incapacitated body stating that their goal is
to take his heart, but as they say this the
ghost devil's dying hand is seen floating
towards Denji’s body. SOMEHOW HIMENO LITERALLY
COME’s THRU CLUTCH EVEN AFTER DYING and TEEARS
the cord on his chest reawakening and finally
transforming him into the Chainsaw Man. Though
he’s initially confused by the current
situation he instantly recognizes that
the Katana Man and Sawatari are his enemies.
Like the absolute psycho he is he excitedly
charges at them stating that he loves bad guys
as no one cares how he brutally kills them,
Sawatari noting she is missing fingernails
calls for backup over a walkie-talkie then
looks over at Aki who’s still in
complete shock over Himeno's death.
Denji and the katana man continue fighting with
the katana man showing the ability to easily slash
large areas with a single strike. Two backup
agents arrive and begin firing guns at Denji,
though he gets shot he is able to knock both
of the fodder fools down, then takes one as a
hostage. Angrily the Katana Man who just couldn't
give a fug about this random agent slices through
him and Denji cutting them both in half at a
speed Denji was unable to even register…Picking
up Denji’s mutilated top half, the Katana Man
orders the other agents to get the car around,
remarking that the other members of the fourth
division are likely already dead due to their
vulnerability to guns. (Which if for those of
you wondering if they are dead or not, WELLL
yes just before this fight initially started an
ambush took place in which every member from the
fourth division was merked ANYWAYSS!)
Skipping away from the fight over to mummy
Makima just after she stunts on all of the
fools who somehow thought they took her out,
anyway after coming out the train and meeting
up with some agents, Makima theorizes
that the gun agents are currently going
after Denji. To combat this she orders
Kurose Tendo to find her a shrine with
a high elevation and 30 criminals with life
sentences, as well as a change of clothes.
Back with Denji and his messed up body, a
few Gun Agents move his top half into a car,
but as they do so one begins to weirdly
sweat remarking how strange he feels all of a
sudden. In an instant his body is flattened by an
invisible force horrifying all of his compatriots,
panicked Sawatari calls to team e asking
them to re-confirm Makima's death with
c team. However as they all panic an
a team agent responds commenting that
they've lost contact with c team, but as he
says this he too is flattened mid-sentence.
Back at the shrine as Mummy Makima
enacts her freaking death ritual,
Tendo and Kurose stand nearby as well as 30
blindfolded prisoners who’ve been lowered to
their knee’s being readied for their impending
death. Tendo informs Kurose that due to her high
ranking the nature of the devil Makima has a
contract with is kept completely classified.
Makima then orders a prisoner to say the
name Mishima Shuzo to which he complies,
over at the van the gun agent named Mishima
Shuzo is instantly flattened by that invisible
force. Back at the shrine, the prisoner then
falls dead as Makima who couldn't care less
about the previous dude then instructs the next
prisoner to say another name and so on and so on.
Throughout the entire country multiple gun
agents are constantly flattened over and over
as a result of Makima’s curse.. Suddenly she
stops, then instructs Kurose and Tendo to take
off their blindfolds telling them that she has
done all she can do from their current location.
Back at the van and panicked with the situation
along with people dying around her Sawatari orders
the Katana Man to hurry up and move Denji before
Makima can interfere any further. As he does
this he suddenly sees a random figure moving
towards them which turns out to be the family
supporting girl Kobeni who’s clutching a kitchen
knife. Kobeni asks Sawatari and the Katana Man
whether or not they are affiliated with the Gun
Devil. Not concerned with the arrival of Kobeni,
Sawatari summons the snake devil's tail to
attack her, but somehow Kobeni’s agility
skyrocketed and she easily dodges it before
running along its body towards the two.
The Katana Man tries to shoot at her, but
Kobeni is just way to damn quick and she
easily slices his arm off first, then like on
some matrix level shit she grabs the gun and
shoots him in the back then turns her aim
towards Sawatari. The curse wielder fires
at her first but being Kobeni she has
the worlds biggest brain and actually
uses Denji’s reinforced Chainsaw head to
deflect the bullet. Sawatari realizing
she could die here grabs the katana man
and drags him into the car drives away.
Kobeni looks down at Denji's unconscious torso and
apologizes for trying to kill him in the past..
Slowly as the realization of everything sets in
she begins to laugh growing slowly hysterical as
she remembers Arai’s dead body, before deciding
she plans to tell Himeno that she quits the team.
(Which is hella sad as she doesn't even realize
that at this moment Himeno is currently dead!)
But that there does bring the end of the first
battle to a close, one that I find completely
changes just the overall outlook on the series.
Through this short but insanely brutal first
battle here one in which Denji really isn't
the main fighting force for the first time,
the weight behind what everyone does increases
10 fold because simply we know for a fact that
those characters we considered un-killable as
they were part of they key cast are actually
killable. Its like the moment in FMAB where
Hughes gets ambushed and actually dies,
it changes the dynamic of everything and makes
us realize the enemy wont stop at nothing to get
their goal completed. ANYYWAYS skipping forward
to the beginning of the second battle now,
and of course if you wanna know exactly what
happened in between the two battle’s, CAUSE
OML THE IMPLICATIONS OF HIMENOS DEATH, AKI USING
HIS CURSED TOOL TO MUCH, HIM GETTING A NEW DEVIL,
THE STUFF THAT GOES DOWN IS ACTUALLY MENTAL. SO
IF YOU ARE INTERESTED THEN BE SURE TO CHECK OUT
MY VIDEO GOING OVER THE ENTIRE KATANA MAN ARC
FROM CHAINSAW MAN AS THAT EXPLAINS EVERYTHING!
So as this second battle is about to take
place the bureau (which for all the CSM
newbies is the devil hunters association of
Japan pretty much) well they all prepare to
storm the gun agent's building. Inside Sawatari
talks to the Katana Man reaffirming their plan
to kill as many devil hunters as possible and
steal Denji's heart. Outside Kishibe orders the
hunters to storm the building while at the same
time a pack of zombies lye in weight below them.
Kishibe introduces himself to the second division
leader Furuno and the police officer Shiina who
are in charge of locking down the building,
he gives a rundown of the various non-human
members of the special fourth division inside
the building now fighting. Inside of it we see
this crazy looking shark thing called beam who
appears and begins devouring these zombies,
in his frenzy he accidentally bites another
member of the 4th division, the violence fiend
who in turn knocks him down before apologizing.
Continuing to attack more zombies the violence
fiend notices a woman nearby and warns her to stay
away before realizing that she’s also a devil and
is in fact the spider devil called Princi. She
stands up and decapitates a zombie whose head
falls down and rolls over to the feet of the angel
devil who begins eating away the various bodies.
Aki then shows up on the block and begins
cutting through the hoard of zombies. Seeing
him the Angel devil asks Aki for a hanky
chief to clean some blood off him before
explaining to Aki that he absorbs others
lifespans through touch and is surprised
at how close Aki has gotten to him. Suddenly a
gunman appears and tries shooting at the two,
but Angel simply deflects the bullet while Aki
closes in on the dude and stabs him. He then
continues on his own eventually coming
face to face with the snake bitch Sawatari.
Instantly she does the most messed up thing
you could possibly imagine and uses her devil
to release Himeno’s ghost devil which is now
completely sub-servant to her… Seeing this,
Aki moves forward deflecting most of the devil's
attacks as his new devils ability the future
devil gives him the ability to slightly see the
future, however he is still quickly overwhelmed
by the plethora of arms the ghost devil has and
is soon being strangled by the creature itself..
Going into a flashback, Aki remembers an
early meeting with Himeno, one in which
she offered him a cigarette, however once
she realizes that he's underage she takes
it back and promises him to give it back to
him when he really needs to rely on something.
Back in the present, Aki looks up having
been released from the Ghost Devil's grasp.
From amongst its mass Himeno’s right
arm reaches out holding a cigarette,
taking it Aki sees the words easy revenge
written across it. Taking a deep breath he
steps forward and while remembering Himeno’s
words he reflects that the ghost devil is
blind , so it senses its surroundings based
on fear remaining alone. Keeping himself calm
Aki climbs a top before promising Himeno that
he'll die soon and join her. He then swings his
sword down decapitating the ghost devil and
freeing Himeno from the snakes subservience.
Shocked with the turn of events, Sawatari
moves to summon the Snake Devil but is stopped
by our girl Kobeni who’s holding her good old
kitchen knife to the girls throat. Aki orders
Kobeni not to kill her, then realizing she didnt
actually quit he then asks why she's still here,
to which she awkwardly responds that
she was close to earning her bonus pay.
Over at the Gun agents headquarters
and using an elevator with Denji,
Power begins chomping down on a severed zombie
hand which disgusts Denji, causing the two to
break out into a miniature scuffle. As the two
absolute morons argue together the elevator doors
finally open revealing a large swarm of zombies
in front of them. Due to the zombies somehow not
noticing them Denji recommends they stay quiet
and utilize the element of surprise, however
Power being her usual loud self begins screaming
out and challenging the zombies to a battle..
She bravely steps forward and begins fighting
as a bewildered and annoyed Denji remains in the
elevator. Believing her bro is still watching
her, Power easily slashes away through dozens
of hulking zombies, boasting that she is
the strongest alive! As Denji who stayed
in the elevator arrives on the highest floor
he prepares to tear his ‘let it rip’ switch,
but when the door opens and he sees the
Katana Man along with a few of his agents,
the katana man instantly asks him to
chill for a sec so he can ask Denji a
few questions. He explains his group desire’s
for compensation over the old man's death,
but Denji who’s obviously frustrated tries
explaining again! That the old man was
zombified when he had killed him, however the
Katana hybrid just doesn't believe this. No,
Instead the katana man asks Denji whether he
truly felt nothing when killing the zombies,
reminding him that they used to be humans at some
point. Denji repeats though that he felt nothing.
Big Mr Samurai man then reveals that
despite giving his heart to a devil,
unlike Denji he still feels guilt over killing
zombies. He goes on to say that Denji is the
only devil human hybrid without a sense of
conscience and morality. He requests Denji
to just accept his death as a form of mercy
killing, but our boy who couldn't care less,
casually responds that he doesn't wanna, causing
an irritated Katana Man to take off his hand and
transform into his killing form. With the two
now transformed they clash and crash through a
nearby wall which drops the duo sending
them falling towards the streets below.
The katana man and Denji glide through the
air while still in combat and falling. As
Denji gets pushed back he falls
and lands atop a moving train,
readying himself in time he is able to block
an attack from the still falling katana man
which sends them both crashing into a crowded
carriage. As floods of terrorfied passengers
begin fleeing a voice over announces that
the train is coming to an emergency stop.
Denji notices a single remaining passenger who
turns out to be an injured woman lying on the
floor, as Samurai boy launches another attack
at Denji, our boy like the pure melon grabbing
gentlemen he is blocks the attack while protecting
the woman but loses his entire arm in the process.
The woman thankful runs away as Denji then
angrily shouts that they should ban that move.
The katana man attacks again, easily slicing
off Denji's other arm, he then demands that
as long as Denji can no longer fight he should
apologize for killing the old man and accept
death (Which is like BRO U STILL GOING ON ABOUT
THAT OLD FOOOD HE DIED IN FREAKING EPISODE ONE,
EVEN PEOPLE WATCHING THIS VIDEO SEEN YOUR
GRANDAD GET TURNED INTO A ZOMBIE BURITO)
however Denji refuses stating that as long as he
has his chainsaw on his head he can still fight.
The two clash again however the impact causes
the blade on Denji's chainsaw head to shatter,
the katana man again demands an apology in
return for a swift death but this time Denji
reveals that the Katana Andy was so distracted
with anger that he didn't even notice LITERALLY
being sliced in half by Denji's leg
chainsaw… The Katana Man now revealed
to have been split vertically in-half which
is like damn bro those poor nuts literally
cut in half anywaysss he reacts with a moment of
surprise before his body completely falls apart
into a mass of blood and organs… Standing
above him, Denji repeats the words told to
him by Kishibe earlier on in their training,
‘pray should never trust what a hunter says.’